ihre grüne Familienministerin gegen den
Liberalen Finanzminister
sagte fassungslos hat er hier auch noch
mal wiederholt ja ich weiß das habe ich
auch gelesen das finde ich natürlich so
ein bisschen bizarr nämlich er ist
immerhin der Parteivorsitzende der
Kanzlerpartei und in meinen Augen nimmt
es überhaupt nichts weg von der
Verantwortung von den Grünen von der
Verantwortung von der FDP aber in meiner
Analyse und die sage ich schon seit
vielen Monaten ist das Hauptproblem im
Kanzleramt und du kannst das selber
nämlich her ist der Regierungschef und
da geht's nicht darum dass er als
Regierungschef mit eigene Meinungen
vertreten darf nicht in seinem Streit in
Auseinandersetzung auch ganz hart für
seine eigene Position kämpfen muss aber
wenn man sich mal geeinigt hat und das
ist in meinen Augen das Problem dieser
Regierung dass diese Einigung wenn sie
stattgefunden hat dann nicht zählt
[Musik]